but before we go to this topic,
which is our main topic,
professor frankl, a question: we spoke
of collective guilt or of the
idea of collective guilt. it is debatable wether or not it truly exists, but
in any case, there was something and there is something we also gather from certain
reactions: there was collective
repression of this guilt.
do you believe that now the time has come
and that this television show can contribute
to overcome this repression? yes but I
must say, paradoxically, only
and especially by our standing up
against the concept of collective guilt.
you see, mr. kreuzer, i traveled 25
times to america for
courses or to teach at universities. and always at the end students who
read the book you mentioned, come up to me
and say: mr. frankl, tell us
not just about your experiences in
psychotherapy but in the final
lecture, please tell us about
your experiences in the concentration camp.
and i am already prepared for that and
always bring a box with a few slides with me
which i took at the
former concentration camp of auschwitz,
when i visited many years ago
with two american guest professors
to show them and
explain certain things. so i show
them, for example, the half-bombed
gas chambers. i show them the ramp of
the train station where the first
"selection" took place and i had to walk
up to doctor mengele
who pointed with his finger
right or left - which meant to be or
not be. of our particular transport only
ten percent went to the right side. and
then i show them the barracks in
birkenau, you know, the
former horse stables. into each of these
stables they had crammed 1100 of us.
and after showing them all these slides
i show them one last one
of a a farmhouse, located just about in the middle
between bad wörishofen and türkheim.
türkheim was the last camp from which
i was liberated by troops from texas. and in front of
this farmhouse are a few farmers,
their children, grandchildren .. three
generations. and then I say
to the students: now
look. these are the farmers, who
risked their lives by hiding
two jewish boys
of our concentration camp from the ss.
I always conclude with that, so that the
concept of collective guilt doesn't arise.
the show actually speaks to that,
the wife who follows her jewish husband into the camp.
exactly. mr. kreuzer, it confronts everyone with reality, albeit in an
artistically elevated way. and it gives to the person who is not guilty
an opportunity to
dissociate from the guilt. and it also gives
and opportunity to the one who is guilty:
the opportunity to distance himself from himself
and to grow.
in connection with the
overcoming of repression
the german psychologist mitscherlich
talks about "grief work", meaning
work that has to be done to
finally really mourn. is that
what this show does? i personally do not believe in that because all
these concepts are far too psychodynamically oriented and see the human being
as a bunch of certain
psychological mechanisms and
thereby in a way give him an alibi.
this is about the human core and it
is about personal guilt or
innocence. and there is only personal guilt.
I think I am the only jew in this group
and maybe I have the
right or even the duty to
emphasize: there is only personal guilt
and no collective guilt. and if we
commit the mistake - or the
youth, which was far from it time wise
and not just internally, if we
leave our youth in the belief that
there is collectively guilt, then we cause
the repression and
repressive tendencies.
we have to tell the young person:
if you blame the germans or the austrians collectively
you are doing exactly the same thing, the Nazis, especially the Nazis, did to the jews.
we need to tell people that,
while of course there are differences,
quantitative and certain
differences in style, the organizational,
the technological and so on ...
we still have to tell the people
that one hand should not pride itself
that it was the the other hand which was
affected by a disease and not itself.
it is always the
whole organism that was sick
the whole of humankind. and every single person,
I personally believe, is in principle
if not in the past so in the
future, capable of holocaust, vulnerable to
holocaust. holocaust is in each of us
designed as a human possibility,
or rather,
as the inhumanity as possibility in a human being.
this is perhaps our most important topic
anyway, but we want to come back
to that later. may i ask one last question about the topic,
overcoming repression - your colleague
ringel writes in this context:
it is important that this is not a documentary but something
experiential. because only the
emotional shock, the deep
consternation that this show
has caused is capable
to overcome the barrier in people,
to overcome repression. is that not
what makes this special and the reason why things are starting to move all in german speaking countries,
a willingness to think about all this?
of course the consternation of the audience which is so much talked about nowadays
can only emanate from something concrete and personal.
but I do not want to
use the word "emotionality" because
I would infer something merely sentimental. it is more, it
is about something existential. it
is a confession, as you mr. president
indicated, it is a confession that must set the path for the future and
therefore should be a concern of education.
pease, before we enter the historic core of thematter,
i ask to show the three inserts.